okay good morning everybody uh my name
is Katherine thank you so much for the
introduction thank you so much for
inviting me here um today the keynote is
going to be a little bit about
suspending your disbelief and joining me
on a creative
Adventure I want to know are you ready
to turn a little bit off your
scientist's brain and turn on your
childlike creative imaginative hopeful
brain who who is with me who is with me
okay if you're not into it you can leave
there's coffee there's croissant uh I
will remain here so today we're going to
think through AI without the possibility
for dystopia otherwise known as
imagining a different world one not
inspired by Peter
Tel so six years ago I was invited by
Vincent who is here some which where
Vincent no maybe Vincent is not here but
I was invited by Vincent to Keynote pida
Amsterdam six years ago that was me on
the stage at that point in time talking
about ethical machine learning and at
the time I kind of want to tell you
where I was at I was working in natural
language processing um we were just
starting to see kind of the things that
would lead to uh the Transformers that
we see today and I was extremely
concerned I was worried because research
that I was doing and that other people
were doing were showing that we had
really awful biases in the language
models that we were creating and I was
pretty sure that unless people were
aware of this and unless we were
figuring out ways to combat it and at
this point in time very much from a
scientifical perspective or a scientific
perspective um I thought to myself well
surely this is going to create a bad
situation and so I was invited to
Keynote I gave a talk about how do we
think through labeling data how do we
think through biases in word vectors how
do we think through debiasing models and
at the time this was kind of the Advent
of some of that research and I was
extremely convinced at the time that if
we had awareness and if we had Technical
Solutions and if we also had human Focus
solutions that we would surely fix all
of the problems that I was seeing and I
had deep faith in the community at that
time and this around the time that there
was lots of data for good AI for good
machine learning for good data for
social good and the more that I got
involved in these movements and this
work the more I started to think if we
have data for good what is the other
data if we have machine learning ethical
machine learning what is the other
machine
learning and uh I wasn't alone so we
obviously saw the influence of things
like cabridge analytica there were
things like taots that happened there
was things like PR Pole or the compass
algorithm that you might have heard of
and there was ways that we were seeing
the biases in the world that maybe we
don't want to recreate being expedited
accelerated and very much widened um by
the machine learning models algorithms
and other types of machine learning
systems that we were
building let alone thinking through
military drones uh computer vision and
what that was being used for at the time
and what I I don't know if you know the
r we the baddies but I'm American I live
in Germany I make a lot of inappropriate
jokes um so uh are we the baddies is a
great sketch if you haven't seen it
where two officers of the Nazi regime
ask themselves are we the baddies and uh
they conclude that perhaps they are the
baddies and the more I got involved at
ethical machine learning and the more I
thought through okay do we need just
data for good do we need to just promote
diab biasing models do we need to
promote ways that we can raise awareness
around biasing models the more I
realized that maybe there's a larger
system at play and maybe my perspective
and maybe even lots of research
perspective on thinking through just how
do we create an ethical algorithm how do
we design a system that doesn't
introduce these biases maybe that wasn't
actually the big problems that we were
creating with the work that we were
doing and so I don't know if anybody's
familiar with Kate Crawford's work Kate
Crawford an anatomy of an AI system I
highly recommend taking a look at it she
is also a researcher uh she partnered
with an an artist based in Berlin and
they created a whole map of what an AI
system takes and they went all the way
down to what minerals do we extract from
the ground to create things like tpus
and accelerated gpus and so forth and
how does this whole entire supply chain
from minerals in the Earth in central
Africa all the way to you know me
fine-tuning a model and deploying it via
whatever Cloud mechanism I want to use
right all of this is documented in this
huge beautiful
diagram and the question that I have for
us today is is the problems start when
we're at the algorithm stage because I'm
pretty certain it probably starts before
that and so I wanted to focus in on what
she names data exploitation in this
graph where maybe we
are the highest knowledge workers we're
still workers right just to remind you
we're still workers but we're the
highest knowledge workers and then
there's the labelers right or maybe
there's the people that run companies
that help us label and then there's the
people that actually label and then
there's the people that help scrape and
collect the data right and maybe these
are all different groups and maybe
they're all happening in your company in
the same place but there's an entire
hierarchy of Labor here essentially
that's happening and when we look at
some of the headlines of course of the
uh human feedback for the reinforcement
learning that we love to use now um we
see that sometimes there's Kenyan
workers pay less than $2 per hour right
and there's workers now organizing in
all different parts of the world who are
namely in the global South and who are
namely paid less than the living wage in
order to label the data that we train on
so this issue obviously is something
that I think affects a uh ethical
machine learning but is not often focus
of those research
initiatives and it goes further so I
work specifically in privacy and machine
learning now so I shifted from ethics to
privacy and I shifted from ethics
privacy we'll get more on that later um
but one of the reasons was I realized
that we had a problem with the growth of
the model size that we were having we
were also having essentially
memorization of some of the training
data this has been proven again and
again in research particularly in sparse
areas of your data set there is going to
be some level of replication of the
training data obviously in privacy
perspective that's huge but it's also a
copyright issue it's an intellectual
property issue it's a question of
creative work issue and I think that
what we saw um obviously what we're
seeing with the writer strike in Los
Angeles where I'm originally from as
well as I can highly recommend reading
through papers like this person probably
exists we start to question ourselves um
is what we're doing here helping the
world and helping people and if so
how and finally I kind of went back to
my original rout so I grew up in Los
Angeles California um Los Angeles is a
massive City and it has a lot of
problems uh mainly our police system is
a huge problem and I grew up in uh I'm
going to date myself I was a teenager in
the '90s in LA and if you know anything
about the '90s in Los Angeles this is
when Rodney King was beaten nearly to
death by the Los Angeles police
department and when this happened I was
a teenager and I saw half the city that
I lived in Burn because there was riots
and there was upset and I bring this up
today because that has kind of been
happening in Europe now on and off for
the past few years with a variety of
different causes and I I know that
things are different here and I
appreciate that things are different
here but I do want to point out that
sometimes data is used as a form of
violence and in Los Angeles with the
LAPD is definitely used as a form of
violence there is a gang database that
has babies names in it literally if
you're a baby how can you be in a gang I
don't really understand but this is a
way that data is collected usually from
communities of color from black and La
Latino activists and organizers and also
of course from people that are in gangs
but I will remind you of how LA gangs
came to be so sometimes data in and of
itself is violent and can propagate
violence this is Cedric Robinson um I
had the chance to work with him on my
undergraduate thesis at the University
of California in Santa Barbara and
Cedric is a brilliant man he was the
inventor and creator of a movement
called black Marxism and has authored
the book I can recommend it if you
haven't had a chance to read it and what
Cedric taught me uh growing up as this
little wife girl in La um trying to
figure out what am I going to do with my
life that is Meaningful that is powerful
what working with Cedric taught me is
that I can use the power that I have the
voice that I have the privilege that I
have to create something different I
don't have to sit around and be upset at
the fact that the LAPD is going to keep
doing the LAPD I'm not going to
immediately change the LAPD I can use
the power that I have to build something
different
to think through things differently to
look at the problems today and not get
mired in depression looking at the
problems but instead think through
action that I want to take that changes
the world and when I was at this like
state of data where I was like oh no
because honestly I got to a state where
I was depressed and I was thinking can I
even work in machine learning anymore I
love this work I love thinking through
important mathematical problems I like
working with people I like doing cool
things with NLP and machine learning but
can I do this work and I found myself at
the same state that I think Cedric found
me at and thought to myself you know
what Katherine you can because you can
take the things that you know and the
power that you have and the privilege
that you have and you could do something
new with it and so this talk is a bit
inspired by Cedric and as a bit of a
tribute to him and the work that I was
able the things I was able to learn from
him um but it's also attribute to people
in abolitionist movements it's also
attribute to people in Freedom struggles
it's also ATT tribute to people in post
capitalist movements in new climate
change movements right and I think that
um what I hope for us today is that we
can recognize the problems of today but
shift to something that maybe is totally
different so are you still with
me are you ready to imagine something
different
okay and what I'm going to ask you to do
uh I'll be at the social event tonight I
want I'm going to show you some of my
ideas if you have an idea if you come up
with something if you're already working
on something I want you to come find me
at the social event I want to hear your
Utopia just as much as hopefully maybe
you want to hear my Utopias and I want
us to think together about creating
things because this is a community and
collectively obviously we are much more
powerful than any one person's ideas
alone so my first idea that I would like
to share with you is the potential to
think through llms or really any
multimodal model would also work as well
and to think through these large models
and to think what if we embrace the fact
that they're going to be
biased because they are and debiasing
hasn't been proven to work in any
meaningful way and what if embrac that
their bias and we started creating
multimodal models or llms that allowed
people to represent themselves in
language that is powerful for
themselves so who PE who here has heard
of the Black Panther
Party excellent so the Black Panther
Party was started in the US um some of
the first black panther party members in
La were actually the original founders
of the infamous Bloods and CPS in La so
the Bloods and CPS the two big gangs
that were fighting in the 90s when I was
a kid were the main product of
essentially the Black Power movement and
communities trying to arm themselves and
then unfortunately turned against each
other we can question how exactly that
happened and if uh there was anybody
else involved in them turning against
each other but essentially the Black
Power movement is directly related to
the history of gangs in Los
Angeles and I would like to present my
plan for the UE Newton neural network no
uh maybe and to think through how do we
create powerful language for communities
to speak with language models that
represent a powerful place for them as
humans what do you
think so the idea essentially would be
to try to put community based models to
put these in the hands of people where
they can feel empowered and I think the
uh here's the the first uh the first
point of the Black Panther Party
10-point program we want freedom we want
power to determine the destiny of our
black and oppressed communities and I
think this can give us a a reflection of
potentially what about the queer
Community what about other communities
what about communities the Muslim
Community and so forth what about
communities that directly when we
interact with language models today have
extreme bias against them so I'm I'm not
sure how many of you know it but in the
original GPT if you started any prompt
with two Muslims it ended in a bomb
pretty much so there's whole communities
that are already harmed by models that
we train today that we claim are neutral
which they're not neutral and we could
instead Embrace and create ways for
communities to create their own
multimodel models to represent
themselves in language that's powerful
and to also therefore for example have
their children have the community use AI
in a way that is empowering rather than
a way that is frightening or
disheartening um my main focus now is
privacy and I got involved in privacy by
seeing some of the ethical issues that I
saw in machine learning at the time
which involved of course the overfitting
of models and therefore the memorization
of some of the training data as we
increased model size but also of the way
that people's consent was essentially
often not even taken into account and I
thought to myself if people could
consent whether they're interacting with
a language model or interacting with
some sort of AI or machine learning
model If people could consent and also
say hey I want my data used for this and
not for that I thought to myself people
are pretty smart they're not going to
opt in as much to things that hurt
themselves and they're going to
hopefully start to try to choose things
that make them feel better so instead of
Doom scrolling we would maybe have joy
scrolling or something like this but the
first thing that you need to do for that
is you need to actually start thinking
through how do we communicate with users
about data that they want to give us how
do we communicate with users about what
their choices are with their data and
can we give users more options that are
also privacy friendly so that they their
data is not at some point in time used
for something that is against their will
of their consent and so here is one
example of a maybe a more fine-tuned
consent model with even options such as
keeping data local Federated learning or
also anonymizing data and not sharing
other parts of data so this is all
something you can read about in my book
uh and just to let you know there will
be some free copies of my book today uh
some available at the piles booth and
some available as part of the pub quiz
so if you would like to get a signed
copy today make sure um you either go to
the quiz or drop by the pie ladies Booth
but I think we can build things where
privacy is automatically built in where
it's not a luxury that you pay for but
it's instead a normal way that we
interact with our users and by doing so
we can also start to guide the
conversation around what data do we
actually need what data do we use for
that and how do we not mistakingly
encode bias by collecting extra personal
information for for example postal code
and these types of things often also
reflect other types of information such
as income and
demographics there's other things so I'm
assuming here that we have some some
lovely folks that work like in the ad
industry or at booking.com optimizing
search results and these types of things
you don't have to raise your hand but if
you want to this is a problem that a lot
of us are working on and I met brilliant
brilliant people who who are playing
what I would call AD war games um where
you're really trying to fight against
the other person and hey that's still
cool stuff I'm not trying to say from a
technical point of view that's not
really cool and I don't want to um
affront your work or anything like this
but what I am saying is what if the
problems we were working on were
actually the biggest problems that I
personally think the world is facing
right now and unfortunately
the biggest problem the world is facing
is not what advertisement somebody
clicks after they search for something
the biggest problems that we're facing
is obviously the climate catastrophe
that we're in is things like housing
right I had a chat uh with somebody in
Amsterdam this morning uh the the
housing price in Amsterdam is just as
awful as it is becoming in Berlin things
like critical infrastructure so Railway
systems other types of critical
infrastructure even of obviously
creating energy grids that are
sustainable for a long term and things
like education so um I know that here is
probably just as impacted as in Germany
with not only an influx of of a variety
of refugees of different ages all of
whom don't speak German so the school
systems in German they don't speak
German how do we keep up so that the
education can reflect and help grow the
future of Germany and here the future of
the Netherlands right or wherever it is
that you may live and I think that if we
were work using the most Brilliant Minds
of machine learning and Ai and math and
physics and all the other things that
you've studied in this room to focus
exclusively on these problems we might
have a very different picture of how
some of these problems work um I've Had
The Joy over the past year of working
very closely with a let's just say a
famous public transportation company in
Germany which you may have uh had a a
chance to be a part of and I think the
impact that I've seen the teams that
I've been able to lead there have in
just a short short time so six months
has been massive because they're
understaffed they're overworked they
often haven't had time to think through
things like machine learning models and
where it can help them and even just
slight nudges in those directions and
putting Tools in people's hands can free
up their time to actually think and use
their also their brilliant mind
to focus on the problems that they're
focused on how do you build out a
transportation grid how do you move to
Green energy how do you get people to
places on time so on and so forth so I
think if we had more government-led AI
initiatives and more of government
funding and NGO funding for the AI that
we're building that might significantly
change the types of things we're
building and I'm pretty sure it will
also significantly change the type of
research that we decide to invest in and
I think that that could be a fairly cool
future another thing another idea
potentially and it's not super far from
the llms Run by communities but this one
I think is more about getting to a local
level or getting to a communitybased
level even if that Community is
distributed uh one of the things I had a
lot of time on my hands during Corona we
had uh fairly significant lockdowns I
know that you had them here as well one
of the things that I started thinking
about is I live in a a building there's
about 20 neighbors and I thought to
myself ah it would be a cool project if
we could get the energy grids from the
windows and we could connect them all up
and maybe I could even write an
optimization model that's like oh I know
my neighbor's going to be gone for a few
weeks I will run her energy to my house
or I'm going to be gone for the rest of
the day I'm going to be at the office
when it eventually reopened so I'm going
to run into my downstairs neighbor and
so on and so forth unfortunately in
Germany we have a lot of regulations
around this I found out very shortly
thereafter um and I'm not allowed to do
a lot of my ideas but I'm working with
some people in Germany who know about
energy to try to figure out is there
some which way to to work through this
but the main idea still holds the idea
that if you have data locally and you're
the machine learning person in the
building you're the machine learning
person in a community um is there not a
way for you to help create new types of
initiatives that are solving some sort
of community problem that you're facing
right in this case it's rising energy
costs in Germany but in your case it
might be something totally different and
what I want you to think about and what
I want you to ponder is if you weren't
doing the stuff you're doing for work if
you had let's say one or two more day
free a week and I'm I'm not asking you
to give up your job I just want you to
think with me
what community thing would you want to
be involved in who would you reach out
to what communities are you already a
part of where could you get
inspiration because again kind of going
back to what we're optimizing for what
we're trying to work on I think that
sometimes uh we get kind of in tunnel
vision of the problems that we're we're
facing that's totally fine that's very
human and normal but I think it it
allows us then or we fail then to see
the creative options that are right
around us for different ways that we can
work with communities and people to
create different types of machine
learning and another thing that I want
to mention here is just the community
doesn't have to be in your building it
can be a community that you interact
with online it can be a global community
and I think that there are ways
obviously I'm a big fan of Federated
learning or distributed machine learning
but there are ways for us to Think
Through connecting data even from
disperate sets where we can build in
privacy where we can also solve
interesting problems and I challenge you
maybe to think through those and how
that might change the types of things
that we're optimizing
for and finally uh I want you to embrace
kind of or try to think about creating a
hacker mindset so who here like has a a
bit of a hacker background or a maker
background something like this of
tinkering with things that's a lot of so
uh so in my age group uh we went to
University during the AI winter we
didn't learn anything about machine
learning in school because it was
believed to be a dead end of course
that's not true we're here today it's
not that's great um but it means that a
lot of uh people of my age group we
really learned about computers and we
learned also about the things that
eventually taught us about machine
learning by doing by playing around with
things by putting in inputs and seeing
the outputs by taking apart machines and
putting them back together and I think
that embracing this hacker mindset today
especially around things like machine
learning would be a really cool way to
not only teach younger people about
machine learning models and how they
work but start to have people question
the systems that they're interacting
with and I think it was amazing to me
when chap gbt got released and to see
the wide variety of people interacting
with it some in awe right of like this
is
Agi and some also though in really fun
creative ways like I'm not sure if uh a
lot of you saw but uh the people that
figured out if you wrote it doesn't work
anymore but if you wrote one character
per line you could get it to tell you
how to build a bomb and how to uh car
jack and these types of things so
creative ways that we we can attack and
interact with AI systems and demystify
some of the ways that they work and I
think that this is really important part
of creating something new because I
think uh I know there's a talk later on
AI Boomers and AI doomers I think that
this is a way to kind of pull apart some
of the stuff the conversation that's
happening around AGI sure we can have a
conversation about AGI I've worked in
crypto for a long time just like we can
have a convers ation about massive scale
quantum computers I think that that
research is still important but I don't
think that that's anything that is the
pressing issue that I see today and
therefore I think it's really important
that we also have people thinking about
the pressing issues that we see today
and that means demystifying machine
learning demystifying large models
demystifying whatever AI is if it's not
machine learning and starting to give
people tools that they can use to attack
these models to Think Through how they
work to change how they work and to
experiment and I think that this is a
significant factor in trying to build
something different and new that is not
essentially being uh let's say plated by
uh the AI
doomers so my ask for you today is
actually not to reform today so let me
tell you about this uh sticker this is a
sticker uh from a group that's called
stop LAPD spying and it's a group based
in Los Angeles based in a la Community
Action Center that I used to organize in
as as a young person that has now of
course evolved it's been some years and
stop LAPD spying is a group of people
that are trying to work on anti-s
surveillance movements in Los Angeles
where we don't have things like gdpr and
we don't have things like privacy
rights and the reason why I want to
point out reform is deadly and maybe
it's not deadly here right we can we can
talk about massive differences in
policing systems and infrastructure but
one of the things I want to point out is
that when we get stuck in a mindset
where today is the only basis for what
we can base tomorrow in if today is the
only way that we can conceive of what
will happen in the future then we are
stuck with all of the same problems that
we've seen today
and that's part of why Cedric's words
inspired me to give this talk today and
why other people that I know in
abolitionist struggles and also anti-
prison struggles and so on and so forth
that the inspiration needs to not come
from today because if we just get stuck
in reforming today then we kind of are
chain to all of the problems that we
already
have and I think that this message is
really significant at least it's
significant for me because there are
going to be people that continue to be
killed based on machine learning systems
and there are going to be people that
continue to be harmed by Machine
learning systems and if I get focused
and focus all of my Creative Energy and
thought on just how do I tinker the
knobs so maybe one less person gets
killed one less person gets hurt one
less person is harmed by some sort of
output then um then I'm I'm destined to
kind of continue repeating that cycle
and I can't imagine something
different but what I do want to inspire
you to do is to think through something
that is your Utopia that's your dream of
what would your machine learning work be
if it was contributing to something that
you think of as significantly important
for the world for your community for
yourself for people around you and I
want you to actually build and work on
that so here is uh Dr Nima Dali staba
she is a close friend of mine and also
the forward author for my book um she
has studied Arabic studies and traveled
the entire Middle East and so forth and
eventually landed in Berlin and she
works in Berlin uh also in uh data and
machine learning background and leading
large technology at a a very large
German company
but what she does in her free time is
totally different first and foremost
she's an angel investor in a variety of
initiatives often led by people in the
global South um startups and different
ideas facing Global South issues and she
also started a group called FR and loop
um that's actually how we met I got
involved in Fr and loop and I helped run
the first machine learning learning
group at fren Loop and fren Loop is a
group of women uh women who have
immigrated to Germany who are looking to
enter the software data or machine
learning World they often have the same
backgrounds as a lot of us but often
less access to the programs that we
might have had so I worked with a lot of
people in bioinformatics who were
physics phds so on and so forth and I
taught them the basics of machine
learning so that they could get their
foot in the door of these jobs and
working with immigrant women uh mainly
women of color in Germany and the
problems and the challenges they face in
entering the career Market even in a
fairly diverse place like Berlin is uh
fairly significant and I think that one
of the things that nikima noticed and
what she wanted to do in creating frown
Loop is to say what is the one thing
that I think that would change the
problems that I see in the world today
and something obviously that you can
have some sort some minor influence on
is maybe a good idea so what akima did
is create FR and loop I'm very grateful
that she did I got to know her and I got
to know a bunch of other amazing people
and I want you to use nikima story
potentially as inspiration for your own
of what is the one thing that you can do
you'll have a long career you will make
plenty of money what is the one thing
that you can do that will maybe change
machine learning change AI change data
change your community in a way that you
would like to see and instead of saying
oh that's not possible or oh it's stuck
in this or oh I can't do it because of
that I want you to still keep suspending
your disbelief and I want you to create
a path create a vision that has nothing
to do with the problems that you see
today other than it will directly work
against them in some which way shape or
form nikima has significantly inspired
me and my work and I think it hopefully
for you also shows a path forward where
machine learning can be a hopeful place
where it can be an inspiring place where
we can help Empower people and really
actually change lives and shift to a new
way where it's very happy to get on
stage and to not talk about dystopias
but instead to talk about things that
are going to be a future that we can all
believe in and to move away from the
idea of being mired in problem
and towards a community that is actively
creating Futures I think one thing I
want to leave here with is the people in
this room are extremely powerful whether
you believe it or not you understand
things that a lot of people in the world
are talking about and they have no
understanding of you have power to you
program things you program the models
that will end up deciding what people
see on the internet deciding what they
think about what's available for them
deciding maybe even sometimes how they
see themselves that is extremely
powerful and I want you to understand to
harness that power and I want you to use
it for something that you believe in
building the future that you would like
to
see if you're motivated I have some
ideas for you I'm going to share them
I'm going to share a note um uh there's
some cool workbooks you can work through
there's of course numerous of the things
that uh I've talked about today
um and one thing that I would encourage
people to do in this room especially if
you're have a European passport and you
can vote and you can engage in political
parties in organizing I encourage you to
do so and there are lots of us that
can't vote here there are lots of us
that are here just you know trying to
live and and find a better life and um I
hope that you use the power that you
have to help create um the Utopia that
you would like to
see I want to thank you so much um for
spending some time with me today um if
you have questions ideas you want to
challenge say Katherine you're wrong
here's why um or you want to share
Utopia ideas uh you're very welcome to
reach out I also have a newsletter
called probably private where I write
more on the technical side but sometimes
these types of ideas as well um and you
can reach out to me there I also have a
PO Box so if you want to send me
untraceable packages you can send it to
my PO Box um thank you so much for your
time today and I'm really excited to
hear your Utopias and I hope maybe I've
inspired a few conversations today if
one of you in this room decides to build
a Utopia based on this um then I have
done my work here and I thank you for
your
attention